hey this is pressure Walker reminding
you to mind your decisions the angles a
B and C of a triangle are in an
arithmetic progression what is the value
of the following it's the ratio of the
sides a over C multiplied by the sine of
two times the angle C plus the ratio of
the side C over a multiplied by the sine
of two times the angle a as is customary
a is the site opposite angle a B is the
side opposite angle B and C is the side
opposite angle C the sides are written
in lowercase and the angles are written
in uppercase you have two minutes to
solve this and you cannot use a
calculator this comes from the 2010 IIT
je e paper one problem 29 and I learned
about it from Khan Academy pause the
video if you'd like to give it a try and
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started by simplifying this
expression
well first use the double angle formula
for sine the sine of two times an angle
is equal to two times the sine of that
angle multiplied by the cosine of that
angle so we'll substitute in for a sign
of to see and then we'll substitute in
for sine of 2a next we'll use l2 seas
law of sines this states that sine of
the angle a over the side a is equal to
sine of the angle B over side B which is
equal to the sine of the angle C over
side C we're only going to need the sign
a over a and sine c over c formulas in
the first term we have sine C over C
well substitute that in sign a over a in
the second term we have sign a over a
and we'll substitute in sine C over C
this makes a over a cancel and C over C
cancel we then simplify and factor out
the two what remains will be equal to
sine of a plus C so we simplified our
expression tremendously now how do we
compute two times the sine of angle A
plus angle C first recall that the sum
of the angles in a triangle in the plane
is 180 degrees we subtract B from both
sides so we get a plus C is equal to 180
degrees minus B we're going to be able
to figure out angle B because the angles
are in an arithmetic progression so
angle a will be some angle a B will be a
plus D and then C will equal a plus 2 D
we add up the angles and we get 180
degrees on the other side we get 3 a + 3
D we then divide both sides by 3 and we
get that 60 degrees is equal to a + D
and a plus T is equal to angle B we
substitute that in and we have 2 times
the sine of 180 degrees minus 60 degrees
which simplifies to be 120
degrees and that evaluates to be two
multiplied by the square root of 3 all
over 2 the twos cancel and we get the
answer of the square root of 3 Wow
now just for fun we can check our answer
using the special 30-60-90 triangle if
we let angle a equal 30 B equals 60 and
C equals 90 notice the angles are in an
arithmetic progression this is a special
right triangle the sight opposite angle
a will be equal to 1 and the side
opposite angle C will be equal to 2
technically the sides are in the ratio
of 1 to 2 but we might as well just say
there 1 & 2 because we're checking our
answer we substitute in the values that
we have for this triangle then the sine
of 180 degrees will cancel out to be 0
so the first term vanishes then we have
2 times the sine of 60 degrees which is
equal to 2 times the square root of 3
over 2 the twos cancel out and we're
just left with the square root of 3 and
we've confirmed this is the correct
answer
incredible thanks for watching and for
making major decisions one of the best
channels on YouTube thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]